لندن تستعجله طالبان الغاء قرارها بشان
المراه وعدد المنظمات المنسحبه يرتفع الى
سته
خيره اوكرانيا بين تنفيذ المقترحات
الروسيه بنزع السلاح او ان يحسم الجيش
الروسي الامر
خطه فيدراليه لدعم ولايه نيويورك الاكثر
تضررا بين العاصفه الثلجيه الحالي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الاخبار من العربيه قال وزير
الخارجيه البريطانيه
ان حركه طالبات تسعى الى اخصائي نساء من
المجتمع عبر قرار حضر عملهم في المنظمات
غير الحكوميه في افغانستان
عبر حسابه على تويتر حركه طالبان
بالتراجع عن القرار بشكل عاجل موضحا ان
قرار طالبان سيحول دون حصول على المساعدات
والامدادات الانسانيه
وكان رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده الى
افغانستان التقى مع وزير الاقتصاد في
حكومه طالبان
القرار المتعلق بحضر عمل الافغانيات في
بيان اللي بعثه الامم المتحده اشاره
الافغان يحتاجون الى المساعدات الانسانيه
وتدليل العقبات لكن طالبان لن ترد ولم
تعلق
افغانستان
خطوه جرت على الحركه انتقادات دوليه واسعه
حتى من حكومات تمارس انواع القمع والتسلط
على النساء كالظام الايراني الجهود
الدوليه والمطالب بالغاء القرار متواصله
الامم المتحده الى افغانستان حتى القائمه
باعمال وزير الاقتصاد في حكومه طالبان على
الغاء خطوه حظر عمل موظفه منظمه غير
الحكوميه بعثه الامم المتحده للمساعده في
افغانستان قالت في بيان ان ملايين الافغان
بحاجه الى المساعده الانسانيه ومن الضروري
تذليل العقبه الموجوده وزاره الاقتصاد في
حكومه طالبان سبق ان حدثت جميع المنظمات
غير الحكوميه المحليه منها والاجنبيه بمنع
موظفيها من العمل حتى اشعار اخر
الاوامر لا تنطبق بشكل مباشر على المتحده
لكن المنظمات غير الحكوميه التي يشملها
القرار تتولى تنفيذ الكثير من برامج الامم
المتحده ما يهدد بازمه اخرى ستواجه النساء
والاسرى الافغانيه لتضاف الى كل الازمات
التي يعاني منها الشعب الافغاني بلال
الوجديني العربيه
بحضر عمل النساء في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
ما يرفع اجماليا المنظمات التي علقت
نشاطها الى منظمات
وكريستيان عيد البريطانيه طالبان على
الغاء الحظر معربه على سيفها لتعليق عملها
في افغانستان كما اثرت منظمات اخرى بيان
مشتركا ممثلا وهي سيف ذا شيلدرن اوكي
وافقولي ردي روسيه على مقترحي اوكرانيا
العقد قمه الاسلام قال المتحدث باسم رئاسه
الروسيه
لم تتبع ابدا شروط الاخرين بل تلتزم فقط
باحداث الخاصه ورد اذا كانت موسكو للتفاوض
في ظل ظروف معينه
صرح في وقت سابقا سلطات الاوكرانيه ترغب
في عقد قمه سلام بحلول نهايه فبراير
المقبل
من جهه قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
بشان نزرع السلاح والقضاء على النزعه
النازيه في اوكرانيا معروفه جيده
من اجل مصلحتها ولا فين الجيش الروسي
الركراني
جميع الموارد المتاحه لهم وهي موارد كبيره
لتحقيق بعض التقدم على الاقل واشكر كل
اولادنا الذين يقفون في مواقفه
ليس فقط
مدينه موسكو وكيف هذا العام اجواء اعياد
الميلاد وراس السنه ضمن ظروف خاصه تبعا
لوضع النساء بين البلدين واقعه الحرب
القاب ظلاله على الاحتفالات وزينه المدن
بالرغم من المفارقه الكبيره التي تعكس
ظروف الباعشيه للشعبين الروسي و الاوكراني
هكذا يبدو مركز مدينه موسكو مستعدا
للاحتفال بعيدي الميلادي وراس السنه في
وقت تدخل فيه عمليه البلاد العسكريه
الخاصه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه شهرها
العاشر انه كان يشتغل وقال حربي محزن
للغايه او للاسف الحرب شيئا واقع ومتكرر
في الحياه التاريخ يعيد نفسه ولا يمكن
للاسف تغييره هذا
اما العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف ها هي شجره
الميلاد في ساحه القديسه صوفيه تقف مزينه
تتركز على ضوء خافت من مولد يعمل بالوقود
ولفترات محدوده ولاول مره بالوال العالم
الاوكراني وفي مكان نجمه الميلاد رمز
الدوله الاوكرانيه وعلى الرغم من غياب
خيام الحلوى والمشروبات الساخنه
والاحتفالات وباحات التزلج الا ان بهجه
الاعياد حاضره رغما عن ظروف الحرب
الحلوه والمشروبات الساخنه لكن على اي حال
يجب ان نحافظ على روحي اعياد الميلاد لان
شبابنا المقاتلين في الجبهات يريدون ان
يواصل الناس حياتهم
في موسكو المكان والزمان يحكي اياني
مفارقه كبيره الزينه والاضواء تملان كل
ارجاء المدينه لاعاده البهجه والفرح
للمواطن الروسي في ظل الاوضاع الراهنه
خاصه ان الشريط الحدوديه للبلاد يعيش حاله
توتر وسقوط عشرات الصواريخ يوميه
اقرباء في اوكرانيا ونحن شعب واحد وهذه
حقيقه
للاستسلام تبحث عن ما يمكن ان يطفي روحها
اعياد الميلاد في المدينه فكانت الحاجه ام
الاختراع لذا ابتكرت محطه قطاراته هذه
الفكره تمام
الطاقه ده دراجه رياضيه تحول الطاقه
الحركيه الى كهرباء لتضيء شجره الميلاد
التي تزين الصاله الركاب
احساس رائع جدا انا ارى في ضوء هذه الشجره
بلادنا الحره المستقله
حميمه لاجتماع الاسره حتي ان البعض يطلق
عليها تسميه العيد العائلي عدد من الشباب
يحتفل بغصه في الحلق هذه السنه بعيدا عن
جو العائله الى هرب من التعبئه والعديد من
العائلات الروسيه تستقبل عمها الجديد خارج
ديارهم التي لا طالما زقزقت فيها شمعه راس
السنه الجديده ورقصوا على انغامي تمنياتي
من حبي والسلام وبعدين كانت شوارعها سابقا
ترقص وتغني بزينه العيد ويختلط ليلها
بنارها بمشهد الرائعه هذه هي كيف تقابل
اعياد الميلاد والاسر والاكرانيه في حاله
من الشتات فالنساء والاطفال يغادروا
بلادهم والرجال منتصرون على الجبهات
والباقونه يواجهون اوضاع الانسانيه كارثه
ولسان حالهم يقول باي حال عدت يا عيد
تظاهرات جديده للجاليه الكرديه في فرنسا
للمطالبه باعتبار الهجوم على المركز
الثقافيه الكردي عمليه اغتيال السياسيه
بعد هجوم يوم الجمعه
لم يتحول الى فوضى على غرار تظاهره يوم
السبت فغبت شعاره السياسيه ضد تركيا
وحيدا لم يتغير هو مطالبه المتظاهرين
السلطات الفرنسيه بالاقرار بالطبيعه
السياسيه للهجوم وخصوصا ان المتهم
بالاعتداء يواجه تهمتي القتل ومحاوله
القتل على اساس انه عنصري وفق مصدر قضائي
فرنسي كشف ايضا ان المشتبه به بالاعتداء
الدامي سائق قطار متقاعد يحمل جنسيه
الفرنسيه واقارب اعترافات صادمه بينها
رغبته عدد اكبر اضافه الى انه يكن كراهيه
مرضيه للاجانب
الرجل قرر قتل الاكراد واتى الاستهداف في
المركز الديمقراطي الكردي الذي اتهمه
اردوغان وحشيته بانه مركز غير قانوني
لمنظمه غير قانونيه
فرنسي في حمايه اماكن كوردي حساسه تقول
بيرفين السيد الكرديه الاشهر في فرنسا
اليوم ان ذلك لم يتغير برغم الاعتداء
الدامي
لكن على اي حال نحن نتلقى التهديدات عبر
البريد الالكتروني والرسائل النصيه على
هواتفنا
ليس تقليلا من هول المصيبه بالافتقادها
عناصر وادله تنفي فرنسا حتى الان وجود
ارتباطات لمنفذ العمليه مع السلطات
التركيه محاوله ربما لعدم صب الزيت على
علاقات متعثره لا ترغب باريس بزياده نار
مع انقره التي استدعت السفيره الفرنسيه
احتجاجا على ما اسمك بالدعايه السوداء ضد
تركيا
وهو انتظار ما ستؤول اليه التحقيقات فادي
دهوك العربيه باريس
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد الفاصل
البرازيل تعزيز الاجراءات الامنيه لتنصيب
الرئيس لولا ديسلفا بعد الكشف عن تهديده
اهلا بكم من جديد اقرر رئيس الامريكي
جوبيد خطه فيدراليه لدعم ولايه نيويورك
الاكثر تضررا من العاصفه الثلجيه التي
ارتفعت حصيرتها في مختلف الولايات
الامريكيه الى 50 قتيلا على الاقل
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده تواجه وعواصف الثلجيه
وصفها خبراء الارصاد الجويه بالاقصى منذ
عقود في دليل على الظواهر المناخيه
المتطرفه في العقود الاخيره عاصفه الثلجيه
اسفرت حتى الساعه عن سقوط عدد كبير من
الضحايا اضافه الى خسائر ماديه كبيره
وتعطل مظاهر الحياه في اكثر من منطقه
وولايه
نيويورك
خلال عطله عيد الميلاد
بسبب الثلوج التي صنفتها سلطات نيويورك
بالعنيفه والتي تضرب بافالو ثاني اكبر مدن
الولايات منذ اكثر من اربعه عقود
لقد اكد لي كبير الموظفين في اداره رئيس
سبايدر بانه هو خلال فتره بسيطه
سيتم الاستجابه لطلب الاغاثه هذه الاخبار
ستشجعنا على حصر الاضرار لهذه العاصفه
التي يمكن ان نراها مره واحده في حياتنا
ومع تدهور الاوضاع المناخيه في الولايات
الامريكيه وتعرضها للعواصف الثلجيه تكثف
هيئه الارصاد الجويه حملات التوعيه لتحذير
الامريكيين من خطوره السفر او التنقل بين
المناطق التي تشهد عواصف ثلجيه مع التشديد
على ضروره طلب المساعده في حال الضروره
الملححه للسفر
قال القياديه في قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
العميد علي حسن ان هناك عمليات تنشيط
متواصله بعد هجوم الا داعش على مقالات
مبنيه بينها سجن في شمال سوريا
[موسيقى]
وبدات بعدها عمليه تمشيط واسعه وما زالت
مستمره عمليه التمشيط كل ما تزداد تهديدات
تركيا لمناطقنا كلما ازداد نشاط الخلايا
همم الارهابيه
قال وزير العدل البرازيلي الجديد انه سيتم
تعزيز اجراءات التي تنصيب الرئيس المنتخب
بعد اعتقال رجل لمحاولته تفجير قنبله في
البرازيليه
بعد الكشف عن مخطط لتفجير قنبله في ساحه
انتظار السيارات
بمطار المدينه
ارتفاع التضخم الى انكماش عدد من
الاقتصادات وذكر التقرير الثانويه للمركز
ان حجم الاقتصاد العالمي تجاوز المئه
ترليون دولار للمره الاولى هذا العام لكن
النمو سيتوقف العام المقبل
سياسات الماليه في معركتهم ضد معدلات تضخم
مرتفعه وكان صندوق النقد الدولي حضر في
اكتوبر الماضي اكثر من ثلث الاقتصاد
العالمي سيواجهم كماشا العام المقبل
عالميا
هل انتهى العصر الذهبي لشركات التكنولوجيا
اغلب الشركات التي ازدهرت خلال الجائحه
تواجه اليوم تحديات كبيره بسبب خليط من
العوامل ماذا فعلها للاستغناء عن عشرات
الالاف من الموظفين هذا العام
متوسطه ولكن موجه التسريح الان طلت عمالقه
التكنولوجيا مثل متى وامازون واوبر
لدرجه انه تم تاسيس موقعا الكتروني ليا
في المفقوده التي تجاوز عددها 150 الف
وظيفه هذه السنه ورغم ان لكل شركه اسبابها
الخاصه الى ان هناك عوامل مشتركه على
القطاع اولا العديد من تلك الشركات عينت
الاف الموظفين خلال جائع استجابه لطلب
متزايد على خدماتها وامل يدوم اسلوب
المعيشه الرقميه مات مثلا عينه اكثر من 15
الف موظفا في اول تسعه شهور من السنه
الجاريه ولكن قبل اسابيع اعلن مرض مؤسس
شركه انه سيسرح احد عشر الف موظفا اي 13
في المئه من القوى العامله
امازون بدولها اعلنت الاستغناء عن عشره
الاف موظف في اكبر عمليه تسريح في تاريخها
على هذه الشركات ان تواجهها الواقع فهم
واجهوا عده فصول من تراجع الارادات والكل
يتساءل ماذا ستفعل الشركه لتعامل مع
الاداء الصعب والتحديات والنتائج المخيبه
ولكن ايضا ماذا ستفعل استعدادا لسنه
القادمه التي ستكون صعبه والعديد من
الشركات اخذت خطوات للتسريح منها تويتر
وامازون ومجتمع المستثمرين يودوا ان تكون
الشركات اكثر انضباطا وتشوفا
عامل اخر وهو ازمه تكلفه المعيشه وارتفاع
معدل التضخم هذا بدوله ادى الى تراجع
الاعلانات عبر الانترنت والمنصات الرقميه
كما ان بعض تغيرات في قواعد الخصوصيه لدى
شركه مثل ابل ضربت سوق الاعلانات وفي مجال
التكنولوجيا الخدمه الماليه طلقت الشركات
ايضا ضربه من ارتفاع اسعار الفائده
المستثمرون ايضا زاد من ضغطهم على الشركات
لخفض تكاليفها
قامت العديد من هذه الشركات بالاستثمار
للنمو على المدى الطويل ولم تهتم بالربحيه
اعتقد ان هذه الاستراتيجيه انتهتماما ويجب
على الشركات اعاده ترتيب اولوياتها
والتركيز على المشروعات والمبادرات الاهم
فقط والعمل لنمو اعمالها وتحسين الاداء
الماليه لان المستثمرين لن يصبر 10 سنوات
كي يرون نتيجه الاستثمارات يجب ان يتخذوا
القرارات الصعبه
الى مصر الذي فصل نصف موظفي تويتر هو من
انصار ضروره خفض التكاليف في شركته
الجديده التي تواجه تحديات في زياده
ارباحها واضافه مستخدم جدد كما يرى البعض
ان رواتب ومزايا الموظفين في القطاع
التكنولوجي غير مستدامه واعلى من غيرها من
القطاعات ولكن ماذا عن اثر كل هذا على
المستثمرين في مجال التكنولوجيا الاجابه
تعتمد على حجم وطبيعه الشركه اذا كان
التسريح مجرد خطوه اخرى في طريقه انهيار
الشركه سن مثل هذه الاخبار لن تعيد الثقل
المستثمرين ولكن اذا كان الهدف من التسريح
خفض التكاليف فهذا قد يكون مرحب به من قبل
المستثمرين لانه قلت يؤدي الى تحسن
الربحيه لندن
والله مع وقفتنا اليوميه مع ابرز احداث
يوليو من هذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يعني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ستكون المملكه بدورها في هذا المجال حيث
ان اعلنت عن زياده مستوى طاقتها الانتاجيه
الى 13 مليون برميل يوميا وبعد ذلك لن
يكون لدى المملكه اي قدره اضافيه لزياده
الانتاج وندعوران باعتبارها دوله جاره
يربطنا بشعبها روابط دينيه وثقافيه الى
التعاون مع دول منطقه لتكون جزء من هذه
الرؤيا والتعاون مع وكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه والوفاء في هذا الشهر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سكس
[موسيقى]
العرب
اوكرانيا بين تنفيذ المخترعات الروسيه
بنزرعه السلاح او ان يحسم الجيش الروسي
الامر
ولايه نيويورك الاكثر تضررا من العاصفه
الثلجيه الحاليه
[موسيقى]